oh my goodness you guys I'm so excited
today's video is going to be so much fun
I partnered with Best Buy to Showcase
some of their e-bike and e-scooter
options they have so many available on
their website so if there's one that
you're looking for you can definitely
find the right ride for you these are
the three that I have picked out today
let's check them out
[Music]
now before we get into the Bikes let's
check out this Segway ninebot d40x I
love a Segway ninebot product so I was
super hyped to check this out because
what really makes it so unique is this
scooter actually has an optional seat
you can remove it if you want but I like
to be able to sit and scoot this has a
high capacity battery so we're going to
get up to 23.6 mile range with a max
speed of 18.6 miles per hour it's got
three riding modes that you can switch
between Eco standard and Sport much like
my electric car this takes advantage of
regenerative braking so as you're riding
energy will be collected each time you
break and give you more power you can
even connect this to the Segway app to
monitor your riding status lock your
scooter and upgrade the firmware this
has been so much fun to ride around now
I tried it both without the seat and
with the seat and I'm not gonna lie I've
never scootered with a seat on before
and this is way more fun than I actually
thought it was going to be it's also got
a little bell which is very nice and
this does fold up you won't be able to
fold it with the seat on but if you do
keep this in the traditional scooter
mode you can Fold It Up carry it put it
in your car very easily the other thing
that I really like is this connects to
an app so I was able to update the
firmware you can change different modes
and it also has a guard mode so when I
go into the grocery store I can just
turn this on so when I come back I'm
just going to slide to exit guard mode
so I can continue my ride
foreign
this is the new bqi C3 Pro it's got a
much different frame than the next one
that I'm going to show you but it feels
more like a traditional bike with its
step over frame but of course it's
electric this has swappable twin
batteries that will take you up to 90
miles and up to 28 miles per hour in
pedal assist it has front and rear disc
brakes and has a front light with brake
activated rear tail lights for better
visibility at night I really like the
frame of this e-bike because it allows
you to easily step over it this LCD has
a lot of options that you can customize
and it's easily visible while riding
there's a lot of things that I like
about this bike I really like that I can
just kind of like step into it it does
have kind of a normal bike seat it's
also got this little extended area here
that you can attach things to it has a
thumb throttle as opposed to having like
a motorcycle traditional throttle is
like you gotta gotta go like that on the
handlebars there are two brakes which
are easily accessible right here now to
charge this it does have two batteries
and there's a keyhole right here both of
those batteries are locked in a place so
when you do want to charge it the
charger actually has a dual charger
mechanism it's like a little cable that
will connect to both batteries at the
same time so you don't have to worry
about coming back charging one then
charging the other you can charge both
of them at the same time and it has
three different modes of pedal assist so
when you switch the pedal assist there's
little buttons right here that you can
go up or down for the amount of pedal
assist so as you go higher the more that
you pedal the faster that you're going
to go and this thing goes so fast you
can also turn it off so if you go to
zero it'll treat it like a traditional
bike no electric boost just normal pedal
and that's fun and all but
pedal assist is where it's at it
actually shook me to my core the first
time that I went on the pedal assist
number three I just like instantly went
I was zooming
foreign
[Music]
this retro looking ride has a much
different look than the new bqi C3 but
both are super fun to ride this does
have a heavier frame and a more
motorcycle style look to it with its
bench seat this will let you cruise up
to 16 and a half miles on a single
charge and hit speeds up to 19.9 miles
per hour it has electric pedal assist
and you can choose from five different
power levels I love that this has a
super bright front headlight and the
brake assist tail lights are pretty cool
too this is really great because I love
cruising to the beach for sunsets and
it's always nice to have that extra
visibility driving back so I've been
riding around with the razor Rambler 20
and so many people have stopped to like
ask about it they're like what kind of
bike is that what is that it's such a
unique look because it does have that
more vintage motorcycle Vibe and I
really love that now this has a little
throttle here on the handle so you
basically all you have to do is just
turn backwards and it'll take off which
I'm not going to do right now because
we'll be kicking Up Sand now this has a
little LCD right here and this is kind
of interesting because it has two
buttons and the LCD itself is actually a
button so when you press up and down
that will change the speed and the
amount of pedal assist that you're going
to get these tires are also super thick
and they're way more industrial than
just a regular little beach cruiser
because this is something that I feel
like you could actually take on the
beach this is definitely much more of an
adventure vehicle it has such a bright
front light and I took this to the beach
the other day for Sunset and on my way
back it was pretty much completely dark
so having this headlight not only helped
me to see where I was going but it also
helped for other people to be able to
see me it also has the tail light which
when you're turning it'll automatically
activate as a turn signal so it'll start
blinking to let people know that you're
about to make a maneuver I had so much
fun checking out these three options of
e-bikes and e-scooters from Best Buy
they have so many more to choose from so
if this is something that you're looking
for for your summer be sure to check out
Best Buy because I promise you you will
find one that is right for you I think I
found mine bye-bye
[Music]
foreign